the United Kingdom the country that's
been saying Yas Queen
per century we've been saying it for
centuries
Yas Queen yeah gasps Queen no you check
it held a national election this week
there wasn't actually due to be one for
three years but Prime Minister Theresa
May called it early it's called a snap
election and she did it to consolidate
her power although it didn't quite work
out that way a disaster for the UK Prime
Minister tonight two resumes
conservatives suffering a stunning
setback a goal of securing a stronger
hand for breakfast ago she ations has
backfired spectacularly the snap general
election has ended with a hung
parliament yes this was a or
to be more precise a crumpet buck of
epic proportions
Tereza mate is hanging onto her job by a
thread to stay in power she's attempting
to cut a distasteful deal with the DUP a
hard-line anti-gay anti-abortion party
in Northern Ireland which has opened her
up to even more criticism meanwhile
there are rumors of a leadership
challenge from within her own party by
Boris Johnson a grown man who
perpetually looks like a seven-year-old
who's just spun in circles for two
minutes and is about to throw up
and while to reason they did manage to
win reelection in her own constituency
even that came with some humiliation and
let me explain British politics has a
proud tradition of having all candidates
standing together on the stage when the
results are announced even joke
candidates which means that on election
night as her party was dealt a massive
blow the Prime Minister here had to
stand on stage alongside Elmo who got
three votes as well as howling Lord hope
of the monster raving loony party who
got 119 votes and if you've noticed this
guy right till you hear his name Lord
bucket head
250 900 you can roll your eyes all your
life Tereza your evening just found a
way to get a lot worse
and for the record lord Buckethead is
this guy an intergalactic space lord who
ran on a platform of among other things
the abolition of the lords brackets
except me and stop selling arms to Saudi
Arabia start buying lasers from Lord
head and he did this all while
looking like Darth Vader an
Amazon echo what I'm saying what I'm
saying is British politics when done
well can be very fun so how did Theresa
may suffer such a setback in an election
that just two months ago she was
predicted to win in a landslide well
among other things she ran a campaign
full of mistakes flip-flops and
uninspiring moments like this the
naughtiest thing you ever did oh
goodness me um well I suppose the gosh
do you know I'm not quite sure I had to
confess when in my friends that have
used to run through the fields of wheat
farmers weren't too pleased about that
the naughtiest thing you've ever done is
run through a wheat field I cannot
imagine a scenario and that is ever
naughty unless you're doing it while
high on PCP and a cantaloupe one
of the beneficiaries of the election was
Mays key opponent Jeremy Corbyn he and
Britain's Labour Party vastly
outperformed expectations despite taking
some rough treatment from the British
tabloid so this was a genuinely
impressive performance for Corbin only
slightly undercut by one awkward moment
with a fellow party leader mr. Corbin
was beaming as he arrived at his own
towns in Islington last night so is
high-five with emily Thorne breeze went
a touch too far perhaps
but that's not ideal that's not ideal a
celebratory moment immediately followed
by history's most catastrophic rounding
of second base and look I do not agree
with tourism a on the vast majority of
issues although I will say the tone of
some of the coverage surrounding her
setback was more than a little sexist
the face of Teresa may the look of a
woman defeated heavily made up as if
she'd been in tears earlier her voice
cracking at times I thought and if
there's one thing I can recognize if the
look of a woman defeated it's the one my
female colleagues give me anytime I tell
them to smile more in the office anyway
back to you in the studio Angela see
there it is about the exact expression
I'm referring to there
cheer up old girl you look absolutely
miserable now the whole point of my
calling this election early in the first
place was to strengthen her hand going
into brexit negotiations and though it
has done the exact opposite of that
tonight let's take a look at what those
talks are going to involve because talks
are set to begin a week from tomorrow
and they need to be completed by March
of 2019 which is not a lot of time to do
something incredibly important and
incredibly complicated Britain wants out
of the EU but we've been in for more
than 14 years with our countries our
systems becoming more and more tangled
up with each other more and more in mesh
and we only have two years to hammer out
a divorce deal it's true
this is going to be a messy complicated
divorce and it's a rough analogy but try
think of it this way imagine if Florida
wanted to secede from the union nice
right but but think about everything
that that would actually entail Florida
has a border with Alabama and Georgia
that would potentially need patrolling
any Florida goods going over that border
like oranges or meth would likely be
subject to tariffs and then you'd need
to decide whether Floridians would be
welcome to live and work in the u.s. or
Americans welcome in Florida and that's
before you even get into the tricky
question of who's forced to take custody
of Hulk Hogan the point is Florida and
the u.s. splitting up would be an
immensely complicated process it's a
great idea and we should definitely do
it but it
we'll be easy and brexit is going to be
vastly more difficult and more expensive
to for start a so-called divorce bill
needs to be negotiated where the UK
settles financial commitments that they
made while a part of the EU and some
estimates put that as high as a hundred
billion euros and that's just the
beginning
broadly speaking the question is whether
the UK will have a hard or a soft brexit
and that is a concept that British TV
has repeatedly attempted to explain
sometimes in the most ludicrous possible
fashion the options range from a hardier
brexit to a softer breakfast and what
better way to judge people's political
tastes then through cheese hard or soft
what what better way to judge people's
political taste of through cheese and an
off the top of my head literally all of
the way even BuzzFeed would find tell us
what cheese you like and will tell you
what breakfast you want to be too stupid
for one of their quizzes and they've run
the actual quizzes should you stick this
up your butt and which Olsen twin are
you which is ridiculous because as we
address last week there is only one
Olsen twin if it's gigantic conspiracy
you're being lied to I just don't know
why yet but anyway put that aside that
report actually had some useful
information in it if you can ignore the
fact that it is pointlessly written on
cheese a harder breakfast would see the
UK leave the single market the UK would
then trade with the EU under World Trade
Organization rules would also have more
of a say over our borders so we could
control immigration a softer brexit
would see the UK remain part of the
single market that be continued free
access for EU nationals but Britain's
exports wouldn't be subject to border
checks that's actually a pretty decent
explain although I really must insist
that cheese is distractingly weird
really the only time tea should be used
as a framing device is if you are a
mouse couple posing for wedding photos
and even then it's a little pink recipe
I'm just saying it's never a bad idea to
ask yourself if you somehow couldn't
Instagram your wedding would you still
be getting
married anyway what's the point is
within that hard soft framework are
decisions that will affect a lot of
lives
take immigration there are currently
three million EU citizens living in the
UK and 1.2 million British citizens
living in Europe all of whom presumably
wouldn't mind knowing where they're
going to be allowed to live and what
their rights might be in just two years
time then there's the issue of Northern
Ireland which is part of the UK and will
therefore brexit but the Republic of
Ireland is part of the EU and any effort
to start policing the border between
them will be difficult because there is
a long painful history of tensions on
the subject of that divide the idea of
border checkpoints suddenly splitting
communities again could quickly become a
nightmare so this is a huge delicate
problem which one news report
Illustrated in the most whimsical way
possible if the dog goes on a brief
excursion to the Republic of Ireland and
returns to the United Kingdom just as
easily this dog will you have the
license to cross the border so you'll
have to go to jail now isn't there legal
immigrants now yeah yeah how yes that is
undeniably an objectively silly way to
illustrate an important issue although I
will say I'm not sure there is a better
metaphor for the British Empire then a
jolly chap named pip shows fuchal
respect for a border this bit of land
here is mine and this one too and this
last is very fun to play around it we
haven't even got to what may be the most
difficult issue of all here and that is
trade because pulling out of the EU
single market without striking a
favorable trade deal could expose UK
products to high tariffs and that is
especially worrisome for farmers since
around two-thirds of the UK's
agricultural exports go to the EU not to
mention the significant EU farm
subsidies that would be lost so it's
frankly no wonder that farmers are
concerned and Rudolph's family have
farmed here since 1947 if we leave
without a trade deal he'll be badly hit
we'd have a job to export things because
of the tariffs particularly with
something like these sheep which a third
of all lambs in the country need to be
exported the whole food industry I
believe is a at risk
yeah rub under that's what I do in life
now now listen could they have cut out
of that interview before the pig started
grinding on that post
yes but they didn't because they knew
that twerking pig may actually be the
perfect embodiment of the entire brexit
situation it's in motion already we're
all powerless to stop it and it is
impossible to look away and after how
the British economy will fare outside of
EU negotiated trade agreement that is
also very much unclear some argue that
things could work out great and that no
matter what British products are so
desirable they will find eager customers
all around the world so maybe that's
true
maybe pork pies Marmite mushy peas and
undiagnosed clinical depression will all
take the planet by storm and sure that
is technically technically possible but
there is a massive amount of work to do
before that can happen for instance the
the UK and we'll need to decide which EU
laws regulating many of its industries
it'll choose to keep on everything from
workers rights
to environmental protection it will also
likely need to set up its own regulatory
agencies to replace the EU bodies that
it's been relying on and it may also
need to negotiate new treaties to
replace the 759 a you brokered deals
that it will immediately be excluded
from governing everything from wine to
nuclear power to the 1981 bilateral
agreement with Iceland concerning the
trade of sheep meat and goat meat what
I'm trying to say is any single part of
brexit is a mountainous task and that is
before you get to the tiny little bits
then you understandably haven't even
thought might be a problem 250,000 dogs
and cats go across the British channel
every year trying to work out how the
pet passports work that would take
several months of negotiation he's right
they even have to work out the issue of
pets passports and while they are a
genuine logistical concern pet passports
do also sound like they belong to real
cats and dogs I mean technically
I'm a Persian but I consider myself more
a citizen of the world
you muffin you still use your mouth
to clean your butt you're not better
than me you're not better than me and
remember the entire brexit deal with the
EU needs to be finalized within just two
years and if you're thinking well what
if they don't get it done in that time
well this happens if there's no deal
that leaves only one option the cliff
edge the cliff edge describes the
reality of one day being in the EU with
everything that that means and the next
day being out of it with No Deal
you know there is exactly one instance
in which the melodramatic stock footage
of an old-timey car flying off the cliff
is appropriately news broadcast and
congratulations you've all just
witnessed it because if there is no deal
everything from tariffs to immigration
were basically default to the harshest
possible scenario which could
destabilize the entire country and look
in theory they could get an extension on
the negotiation but that would require
all 27 EU members to unanimously approve
it and I would not rely on that
happening the EU has a vested interest
in making this negotiation as difficult
as possible because however much they
may value the UK as a partner they need
to dissuade any other countries from
pulling out and the EU is already taking
a firm line for instance after the
brexit vote Boris Johnson a man with the
face of a roald dahl character and the
uncomfortable racism of a roald dahl
failed that our policy is having our
cake and eating it well what you
President Donald Tusk dismantled that
idea to all who believe in it I propose
a simple experiment by a cake eaters and
see if it is still there on the bed
there will be no cakes on the table for
anyone there will be only salt and
vinegar Oh al Donald ouch
nothing but salt and vinegar that is
some tough talk or row someone should
probably tell him the British people
absolutely love salt and vinegar just
look at all of our variations on salt
and vinegar crisps so to be honest
threatening the British by saying there
will be only salt and vinegar on the
table it's like threatening the French
by saying there will only be wine and
baguettes or threatening the Swiss by
saying there will only be chocolate and
Nazi gold those are their two favorite
things they like those equally the fact
is the UK currently faces a daunting
task the counter suffices the brexit
vote and Theresa May seems to have
fatally weakened to her position going
into the negotiations making it harder
for her to enact her plan although it
wasn't clear what the that plan was
in the first place
because while she seems to favor a hard
brexit she could be maddeningly evasive
when asked for specifics people talk
about the sort of breakfast that there
is going to be a bit hard soft is it
grade white actually we want to read
lightest blue grexit that is the right
breakfast for the United Kingdom but
what does that mean you're heading into
a negotiation that will set the course
for Britain for generations and you're
naming colors on the flag forget
running through fields of wheat that may
be the most ridiculous thing you've ever
said
and actually you know I apologize to
that guy from before I said there was
literally no worse way to discuss this
than with teas but I was not counting on
Sacher in the Rye here on during a
policy question with a colour
scheme
and know what holiness did not go
unnoticed in fact it is not a great sign
that the single most honest statement
from any candidate in this election
regarding the difficulty of the task
ahead came from a man with a two foot
bucket on his head your Prime Minister
your MP to reason L called this election
about cruxit have we better know what
you plan to do about grabs it no this is
not on the Thursday you are going to be
faced with Prime Minister name or Prime
Minister Corbin against 27 prime
ministers from the European Union it
will be a show you know what I
never thought I'd tell you but that
intergalactic space Lord have a point
look in eight days the UK is set to walk
into a negotiation with no real leverage
no significant political mandate and no
coherent plan and I don't really have a
solution to that but I do have a
proposal for Teresa maybe because at
this point you have basically
everything up and your only real chance
here is to utilize the element of
surprise so how about instead of sending
a Korean negotiator why not send someone
but there is no way they would expect
I'm talking about someone bold I'm
afraid to call it how it is someone with
a firm leather-clad grasp of the issues
someone with a bucket list of demands
and an honest slightly muffled voice
that's right I'm talking about the
intergalactic space Lord Himself here's
the question is he willing to do it well
yes he is and the reason I know that is
we found him contacted him and actually
flew him here to New York
Hey a similar costume and put an intern
in it
yes we could have done that that's
a good point but we didn't and the fact
that we didn't is why I am now able to
prevent to you here tonight your new
regulator
please welcome Lord heads
[Applause]
that's right of your knees our planes
going to make if you are still Prime
Minister by the time that they show and
I implore you send the Dark Lord's the
brothels if you've an absurd idea yet
but it would not even be close to the
stupidest thing that you have ever done
[Applause]